- This was the only
kingdom in all of Africa
where women had an equal voice.
(suspense music)
(bright upbeat music)
We are set in an actual historical world
yet some of our storytelling
is fictionalized.
"Braveheart" was a template
absolutely for the film,
one of my favorite
movies, historical fiction
I think is really the best description.
So many of the elements are
true and that was the fun part
to be authentic to everything
from who these women were,
the kingdom, what was
happening at that time,
the production, design,
everything mirrored
what it really was.
Historically what was going on at the time
in terms of the big battle
between the two kingdoms
and what was going on politically,
socially, economically.
To do that type of world building
for a story like this was fun.
Our characters within this real world
were fictionalized yet they
reflected these real women,
what they went through.
(bright traditional music)
I used the phrase intimately epic
with every department head and certainly,
when I spoke with Danny Hernandez
who's our fight and stunt
coordinator, and also our actors,
it started with the
conversations with them
that the best action is story
driven and character driven.
And the best way to do that
is to have performance within it.
So you guys are gonna be
doing your own fighting
and your own stunts.
And it's one thing to say that,
it's another to have actors embrace that.
Every single one of 'em
wanted to do everything
and kept doing it until
they got it perfectly.
It took Danny to create a fighting style
that an audience could believe
women legit beating men
which is what really happened.
How do you create that?
What does that look like?
A lot of people working together
but it started with the
desire of the actors
to do what I asked of them
which was you're doing it all.
It's breaking it down into pieces.
When this character's
fighting, what is it about?
Giving each vignette that we have
a beginning, middle and end.
And that the knowledge
of seeds that we planted
throughout the film that leads
us to this big epic battle
that some of those seeds
are now paying off in this.
So again, that it is
personal and character driven
and story driven,
that is not just random
violence or random fighting.
It was making it bite size
so that it didn't feel
overwhelming in shooting it.
(bright traditional music)
People do not, even in this
day and age, think of women
as warriors, as fighters,
as having heart and courage.
These women in the 1800s
absolutely had that.
They were the main fighting
force of this kingdom
and they trained for it and
they wanted to be there,
they wanted to be fighters.
They were athletes.
And there was a beauty in their power
in how they trained in
their athletic bodies.
They were praised for it.
We see what happens in this day and age
and it is getting better slowly
but it's still not to where it should be.
The more we can put women
up on screen to show
that we have an innate warrior,
to celebrate their fitness
and their athleticism and their skill.
Again, these are not stunt
doubles doing that fighting,
this is these actors, these
women, Viola Davis did that.
Thuso Mbedu did that.
We can do that, these are not superheroes,
these were real women.
I hope we can see, yes, this is possible.
I can be that.
(soft ominous music)
This was the only kingdom in all of Africa
where women had an equal voice.
On the council, for every
man, there was a woman
who had the equal power
and voice in the kingdom.
The fact that the Woman
King was a real position,
we didn't make up this cool name,
it really was called the Woman King
and this woman was elevated
to a position next to the king
and helped him guide the kingdom.
We're not just putting
these badass women on screen
but we're telling a bigger story than that
of who these women were,
what the society was like.
But also in the research,
I didn't realize how big
dance was to this culture as well.
So not only did these
women train to fight 24/7,
they also created these
elaborate choreographed dances
that celebrated themselves,
got them ready for war.
I loved that I was able
to bring that element
within this film as well.
(soft ominous music)
The Oyo battle, absolutely.
It is an epic battle, I studied
with Polly Morgan, our DP,
we studied "Braveheart", "Gladiator",
"Last of the Mohicans", it
was absolutely this thing
that was looming at
the end of the schedule
but I put it there one, to
give the actors enough time
to train for those sequences.
I needed our crew to be
a place where we were all
so comfortable with each
other, working at another level
before we got into that because
it was absolutely daunting
and we had 11 days to shoot it.
It was intimidating but everybody,
we just had a plan and we
stuck through that plan
and we got it done.
(bright upbeat music)